ça lui est ce que vous allez remarquer
que la plupart du temps on navigue sur
internet sur les mêmes sites en général
on va sur les mêmes sites sur les mêmes
réseaux sociaux et on découvre assez peu
de nouvelles choses fort de ce constat
je me suis dit tiens je vais faire une
vidéo qui s'appelle d'ici qui vont pour
retourner le cerveau je viens de lire le
titre exactement décide que je connais
soit qui me sont utiles soient qui me
font marrer soit qu'ils mettent dans la
créativité je vais vous faire découvrir
ça pour vous emmener un peu ailleurs sur
internet à tout moment j'aurai accès à
loïc via cette boule vercors en mettant
la main regarder ce qui se passe et ça
me connecte directement à loïc du futur
au montage loïc est ce que tu m'entends
oui loïc pourquoi pas voilà on peut donc
dire que cette boule sera la boule de
loïc g
le site que je vais vous présenter au
delà d'un site est une extension qui
sponsorise cette vidéo et que je
connaissais d'avant la vidéo parce que
c'est très pratique et c'est gratuit ça
permet de économiser de l'argent
l'application s'appelle we wanted ça
s'écrit avec 3 e on peuvent aller voir
le titre sur safari google ou firefox et
sans enfant gratuit et le fonctionnement
c'est que ça va détecter des bons
d'achats et des réductions sur les sites
où vous allez habituellement acheter des
choses que ce soit puma rebbouh kavidha
cdiscount à chaque fois ça s'active tout
seul vous fait voir comment ça marche
en 60 secondes à peine quand vous
arrivez sur le site de mon petit vous
installez d'extension en cliquant ici
elle est déjà active est pour moi une
fois qu'elle est installée à sera
visible ici et quand vous êtes sur un
site marchand qui a des codes promos
disponibles wanted le détecte et vous la
fiche ici
alors ça marche sur les sites genre
pouma reybrouck adidas ou des sites
comme sephora comme cdiscount
mais moi je vais aller sur un site qui
m'intéresse parce que bientôt on va
acheter un nouvel ordinateur pour les
montages et donc je regardais les
ordinateurs chez hp j'ajoute au panier
ok voir mon pagne est donc l'extension
de wanted s'activent sur le côté et je
clique sur tester les codes et c'est
parti wanted fait le travail pour moi
cherche cherchent-ils boom
on a déjà 50 euros de moins à payer
assurément tous les codes disponibles
viennent d'être testé et on vient
d'économiser 50 euros appliquer le code
en fait c'est 6 % de remise immédiate
sur les soldes d'été d'extension l'après
midi de dents après avoir tout tester et
c'est déjà appliqué à mon total c'est
simple puisque l'extension s'auto active
c'est rapide c'est gratuit en général
les gens économisent 20 euros en moyenne
sur leurs achats
donc le lien est dans la description
boum ça retourne le cerveau
on commençait avec un site qui s'appelle
kamel kamel kamel points comme ça n'a
rien à voir avec les cigarettes camel ça
n'a rien à voir avec les chameaux même
s'ils en ont mis ce site là est très
intéressant parce qu'il fait une
évolution des courbes de prix des choses
qu'on peut trouver sur amazon pour
pouvoir les acheter au meilleur moment
voire 6 a beaucoup augmenté beaucoup
baissé et c'est je vous fais la
démonstration tout de suite en haut on
marque ce qu'on veut donc moi je tapais
fabien olicard parce que je suis d'un
passage jean ricard dans peuvent
je suis donc en train de me révéler
parce que je suis mes gosses entre et
non pas du tout parce que je suis sur
amazon bien mon livre et on va pouvoir
voir ce qu'il va se passer quand on va
voir l'évolution par exemple de mon
premier bouquin parce que là il ya le
premier lyall deuxième là il ya la
memory boxe et à yaya tout ce que j'ai
fait on clique dessus juste sur le titre
et là on a toute la courbe d'évolution
des prix donc sur amazon là ça bouge pas
parce que je sais pas si vous avez aimé
en france le jan législation sur le prix
des livres ont fait pas ce qu'on veut
donc c'est toujours le même prix prix 9
ou d'un tiers mais surtout prix
d'occasion d'un tiers et c'est ça qui
est intéressant
vous avez toute la courbe d'évolution de
mon livre en occaz c'est à dire que
quand il est sorti assez rapidement il
s'est vendu 40 euros d'occasion 40 euros
un livre qui en vaut 14 95 pourquoi
d'après vous et bien parce que tu as des
mecs qui sont des escrocs professionnels
et qui quand ils voient qu'un livre va
être en rupture il en achète klein et
leur revente d'occasion parce que neuf
on n'a pas le droit de faire ce qu'on
veut avec le prix des livres en france
ils rentrent à 40 euros en dix ans et
c'est quoi
s'il y en a un qu'il veut et qui croient
qu'il est plus édité ben je peux
j'espère tellement que personne n'a
acheté comme ça et en fait vous voyez à
chaque fois la rupture du stock c'est
quand bien quelqu'un qui le vend car
d'autres motards y en a il l'a vendu à 1
5 euro se trouve il est peut-être ils
avaient mangé des pâtes aux tickets
l'article tu veux qu'on regarde en
évolution de prix sur amazon
harry potter et on va voir les articles
qu'ils sortent voir s'il ya des trucs de
connexion des choses comme ça car voilà
bien le vif d'or
ok donc déjà on voit que tout départ que
les sorties l'état à vendre un peu plus
de 32 euros 32 36 trois mois après il
est descendu à 26 euros il a gardé ce
prix là comme quoi ça valait le coup
d'attendre un peu
alors au départ des prix neuf d'occasion
était sous le choc hier que les neuf
d'un tiers mais moins cher qu amazon et
après on voit que l'aïd est descendu
vraiment à 24 euros 53 donc là ça valait
le coup de l'acheter d'occasion
évidemment s'il en bon état voilà
c'était mon premier site je le trouvais
intéressant à regarder parce qu'on peut
voir plein de choses comme ça et on peut
aussi voir si on est en train de se
faire un peu arnaquer ou pas là on est
clairement sur quelque chose de moi
utile c'est the useless web
alors vous savez que sur internet il ya
plein de sites un peu inutile qui traîne
et du coup au lieu de faire voir tous
ces sites un parent j'ai préféré vous
recommander ce site
technitoit useless website c'est y pas
jaloux de mon accent en anglais
un jour vous aussi vous arriverez à
parler aussi mal que moi le but de ce
site c'est que tu as ce gros boutons
rose et tu clique dessus et 7 ans mène
sur un site inutile quand note tweet
zeiss 15 notes prises tweet
effectivement tu ne peux pas ne pas
twitter
alors là on est sur bienvenue le ch
russie de la république des mangues
il ya une mangue avec comme un soleil
derrière et c'est tout maintenant on
sait de cannes si ton parent à ok il ya
deux yeux qui suivent la souris et si tu
cliques il ya d'autres lieux qui suivent
sa souris et d'autres cieux qui suivent
sa souris est en fait tu peux vraiment
te mettras bad et si tu fais ça un soir
que tu rentre tard et que tu a ingéré
dans ton corps des choses qui ne sont
pas bonnes pour des neurones qui peut
vraiment de faire un bad en plus tu peux
les faire loucher de ouf
ah [ __ ] nouveau site en fait issus de
mouvements de la souris mais les trop
stylé mais moi je peux passer des heures
là dessus alors si vous voulez que je
vous donnais un petit ips situe le
secoue très vite il devient comme s'il
était lectrice y est
oui un site
excellent pour le cerveau c'est ainsi
que des skins game mais c'est pas
vraiment un truc d'escale games vous
faire voir ça ce site là à la base il a
été créé je pense par et pour des profs
des instituteurs des trucs comme ça mais
il ya énormément de ressources
si vous aimez créer vous aussi des
énigmes si vous voulez créer des énigmes
ou dskgate moi vous savez j'adore faire
ça ou des chasses aux trésors et où il
ya plein de ressources sur site il ya
des trucs très stylée il ya des petites
aventures escape game affaires grâce à
génial y en a qui programment sa dessus
c'est très facile à faire genre là un
jeu d'exploration et de vocabulaire pour
aimer jeu de focales guerre genre tu
choisi la destination tu vas à belém au
brésil tu vois pilates un avion carré
[Applaudissements]
ouais
quel avion tu dois emprunter on va
prendre l'élémentaire on arrive sur
pedro comment je le sais pas ce que j'ai
déjà fait ce jeu évidemment et pedro je
savais qu'il était du brésil temps on
clique on a des éléments de charade mon
premier flers soigneusement mon second
est une vieille tradition nous trace du
c'ur de transition on a redit que bruni
mon second est une vieille tradition les
traditions ses boîtes boîte best seller
les les us et coutumes et mon premier
c'était quoi c'était flers soigneusement
sortir il mais comme mon tout nourri de
jeunes plants en forêt je dirais yves et
des traditions des us et coutumes us
humus cellule us bonne personne pour
m'amuser public oui
apparition d'un golem et d'un symbole
qui servira sûrement pour la suite
mais voilà ce qui est intéressant sur ce
site en vrai c'est qu'il ya énormément d
aide à la création
comment on crée une énigme comment on
rajoute de la science et de l'éducatif
un escape game moi une énigme comment on
réussit son escape game
comment on peut favoriser l'intelligence
de groupe c'est pour être chose vous
savez que j'aime bien faire des énigmes
mais j'aime bien ancrée et j'aime bien
créer comme les boîtes haining que
j'avais fait pour un mix est moulé tout
comme ça et bella
c'est plein de ressources pour vous
stimulez vous aider et s'est classé sur
le côté par thème bricolage l'habiller
unc livre j'en lis impression 3d idées
et astuces
je vous recommande ce site très
rapidement un site utile pourquoi il va
vous retourner le cerveau parce que vous
allez juste vous dire mais punaise ça
existe comment j'ai jamais pensé à ça
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé dans
ma tête ça fait un big bang quand j'ai
découvert ça ça s'appelle dix minutes
mail et c'est gratuit je viens juste
d'ouvrir le site et ça vient de me
générer un e-mail temporaire qui est
disponible pendant neuf minutes 38 ça
permet de s'inscrire sur un site avec un
email bidon comme ça marche 10 minutes
on a le temps de recevoir la
confirmation pour valider que l'adresse
mail existe et après on aura jamais de
spams jamais de sport il ya plein de
sites
d'une info ou d'un truc où je vais aller
voir un truc sur un forum mais je m'en
fous j'ai pas envie de recevoir tous les
trucs après et en même temps il n'y a
pas besoin de serveurs énorme puisque
toutes les dix minutes après c'est
supprimer
je trouve ça beaucoup trop cool et voilà
l'aï marqué vous avez zéro message mais
je vais le tester
ceci est un test on voit habite
j'ai une anecdote à pourra compter sur
un mail professionnel hier j'ai créé à
vite à la fin a très vite et en fait si
vous voulez des fois là-haut correcteur
automatique fait des trucs bizarres et
en fait j'ai envoyé à ce dirigeant d'une
énorme entreprise américaine a très vite
il est franco combi les sait très bien
ce que j'ai voulu dire ok j'ai un
nouveau message
voilà il est juste là test je peut
l'ouvrir le lire et s'il y avait eu un
lien j'aurais pu le bal idée voilà je
trouve ça super pratique qu'est ce que
vous en pensez dans ce bureau loïc la
nuit c'est trop cool
évidemment c'est trop cool le site
suivant c'est le tir est bon tir et six
points comme c'est un site pour générer
des noms dans plein de choses rentrent
dans la catégorie des sites créatif qui
me retourne un peu le crâne parce qu'ils
sont tellement pratique pour me stimule
et créativement on va se créer un nom de
rockstar genre mon nom fabien je me
mette le feu dans le quartier pourra
j'appuie sur soumettre
fabien olicard votre nom de rockstar et
brett fils mort ok pourquoi pas loïc la
garde car ce gars
mcfadden tu t'appelles mcfadden tu as
des aussi des chercheurs de noms de
sites et de start up je veux ouvrir une
start-up je peux l'appeler zappé ou
qualium ou pixo va ou queen works ou
senti l'yonne et en fait ils te gêne est
en toi tu vraiment qu'il fait un peu web
et juste après l'avoir générer comme ça
o'keefe
tu peux vérifier sur line chip points
comme il ya un relais si ce nom de
domaine est disponible
sauf là le dernier qui kim a validé il
est dispo générateur de nansha votre nom
en chinois un générateur de nom
universel générateur de nom pour vos
enfants ce serait quand même tellement
drôle qu'un jour il ya un an prise mais
pourquoi tu m'appeler comme ça en fait
ben en fait parce que je suis allé sur
un site est vu dans une vidéo de fabien
olicard je cliquais de suisse à te
donner un nom et comme on n'avait pas
d'idée avec ta mère s'appelait comme sa
poche un site à mes sites préférés
il te permet de créer des bd trois cases
oui le style de bd trois cases pour
faire une blague d'un truc des fois tu
veux dire quelque chose du genre sur les
réseaux sociaux et tout et tu te dis
ouais mais si je l'écris comme ça on
n'aura pas l'image que j'ai en tête
et là tu peux faire sur make up comique
ses strips creator tu peux faire laver
des trois cas ce que tu veux vas-y on va
en faire une et pas un vieux monsieur
c'est super ok et je vais le mettre
trois fois on veut poids on veut un
petit bureau pas une salle de réunion au
quai case numéro dialogue docteur j'ai
un problème de mémoire
le docteur va lui répondre depuis quand
depuis quand quoi leur docteur japonais
de mémoires
depuis quand depuis quand quoi voilà une
excellente zag
merci d'arrêter cette blague sur sur
deux dans les commentaires que je n'ai
pas envie de prendre trop de risques sur
la marche sont comme moi vous mettez 1
5% d'hommes récitant j'ai tellement
envie de faire une vidéo sur les chaînes
secondaire avec que des blagues comme ça
que je ferai peut-être je ferai ça qu'on
aura dépassé les 50 mille abonnés sur la
chaîne second dont vous avez le lien
dans la description
le prochain site est extrêmement
addictif
un peu comme un des autres tout à
l'heure si vous rentrez un soir tard
avec de l'alcool dans le sang ou pire
que ça vidal collaboration vous pouvez
bad et est resté devant ça en inde
pendant des heures jusqu'au petit matin
non ce n'est pas une expérience
personnelle vrai ou faux
c'est un zoom infinie sur un dessin tu
te mets comme ça
karl devant et j'ai ce qu'il fait il ya
quoi après la croix près
mon but c'est trop bien dessiner ses
bienfaits ce que les trucs de zoom
infinie que je connaissais moi c'était
avec les fractales donc en fait ça ça
calcule l'intérieur du zoom en
permanence et là c'est un dessin qui ne
s'arrête jamais qui ne s'arrête jamais
des fois ce qui se passait quand tu veut
stopper mais en fait comme le dessin
apparaître qu'il dit moi mais je vais
quand même regarder le prochain titre
est assez créatif et l'autre se serait
ainsi pour le cerveau qui traite et cool
d'ailleurs sa seat que j'aime bien
qui te permet de générer des histoires
interactives
donc c'est très cool ça site gratuit
c'est intel studio et donc tu peux créer
en fait un histoire interactive c'est un
peu comme les livres dont vous êtes le
héros ou les vidéos interactives que
j'ai fait comme la seconde celle ci où
les autres sans description tu fenioux
tac tu crées dans l'histoire je suis
allé dehors tisser un narrateur à la
première personne est apte ajoute les
options et j'ai pris à droite a ajouté
une option mais je suis resté chez moi a
ajouté une option et j'ai pris à gauche
c'est vraiment une histoire passionnante
l'accueil que je vous propose
ok et ensuite vous écrivez la suite
follow this option si tu suis ici on va
arriver où un combat arrivé à mais j'ai
regretté
j'aurais dû prendre trois petits points
a ajouté une option à gauche a ajouté
une option etc et tu fais tout ton truc
à tout moment tu as accès à toutes les
sections pour voir un petit peu de temps
mais qu'est ce que tu as oublié de
linkey etc etc je trouve ça trop cool en
fait j'ai découvert ça je vais pas vous
mentir les quelques jours à peine et je
n'ai qu'une envie c'est de créer une
histoire du style
vous êtes le héros j'ai déjà toujours eu
envie que ça mais là l'outil il est
libre d'accès il est très simple et je
pourrais vous mettra près sur instagram
pour que vous fassiez vas-y ont fait ça
ou pas dites moi si on fait ça le
dernier site ça incite vraiment pour
vous retourner le cerveau de ouf avec
des exercices sur les couleurs sur la
concentration sur la mémoire
voilà par exemple talent jeu de
localisation si tu lui lance juste pour
voir ce que c'est en fait tu te fais
avoir tout de suite parce que tu es là
ok bon bah c'est 1 2 3 4 d'un arbre est
en fait il te dit où était le 2 il était
là mais du coup ça avance le prochain
niveau que du coup après tu es chaud
donc au fur et à mesure du niveau ça va
toujours augmenter en termes de
difficulté tu auras de plus en plus de
case je crois que c'est toujours le même
temps mais il ya de plus en plus de
cases à l'intérieur genre la voilà il ya
un an + 2 116 534 très facile à retenir
dès la fin du tac 334 534 voilà ta
gueule ok très bien de parler en
mémorisant donc peu testé ta mémoire de
plein de manières différentes avec des
séquences avec des motorisations pure
avec des reproductions de séquences ici
lors des couleurs sache pas très bon à
sa 15e des séries
en fait je parlerai moi parce que parler
en mémorisant c'est compliqué tout
d'abord vous aurez besoin de mémoriser
l'ordre des couleurs de gauche à droite
deuxièmement vous serez invité à
sélectionner les couleurs ok c'est parti
on a du bleuet double cliquer sur les
couleurs refaire la wii il faut refaire
l'ordre initial d'accord tain c'est bien
parce que là j'ai pas de moyens
mnémotechniques là si c'est vraiment
juste sur la mémoire visuelle
plus claire et vendre aux jeunes ok
pascal les deux identiques la blague est
fausse et quand c'est l'aide
merde je suis même pas sûr de parler en
même temps vas-y les chiffres au
pourquoi pas [ __ ] faut retenir ça
c'est seul niveau 1 à temps en temps je
recharge watts mais c'est quoi ce jeu
qu'après faut les restituer ah ouais il
ya des trucs qui sont tendus car même
moi qui ai vraiment l'habitude
d'enregistrer des séquences de chiffres
là j'étais pas d'accord
n'oubliez pas que je vais poster les
petites bd que je veux faire sur
instagram ainsi que quand j'aurai fini
de faire le petit truc interactif site
très très chaud pour faire une histoire
merci beaucoup à wanted avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo vous avez le lien dans la
description pour télécharger l'extension
extrêmement utile 100% gratuit merci à
eux et les liens vers tous les sites que
je vous ai présenté son dans la
description également petit rajout
confidences de vous à moi vous avez
remarqué que depuis un mois et demi je
ne vous demande publique et les vidéos
vous abonner donc voilà je j'ai vu que
le taux de l'aïe qui était descendu donc
en fait je trouve ça cool d'arrêter de
le dire dans toutes les vidéos comme
tout le monde le fait mais en fait j'ai
la preuve étant que quand on ne dit pas
vous y pensez - voilà c'était une
confidence ciao